later on this week what a week three
slate there are so many dynamite games
where
there are teams that are hoping to go
3-0 then there are desperate teams
hoping to avoid owen iii needing that
first win
um and that um is exactly the way to
describe the houston texans
visiting the pittsburgh steelers who are
2-0 going to this game
with big ben looking the way that he's
looking and the defense looking the way
that it is looking
there's a lot of people talking about
the steelers to go to the big bowl
and joining us right back here on the
rich eisen show right in the middle of
that steller's steelers
that stellar steelers defense said that
ten times fast devin bush
back here on the show how are you doing
devin good how you doing rich i am doing
just fine
how you enjoying playing right now you
must enjoy this i'm so happy
uh i remember a couple months ago man i
i was out of a job
so i got my job back what do you mean
what are you talking about
you know exactly what i'm talking about
well just the fact that there would be
no season is that what you mean
the fact that we were all in our house
for two months
right and now here you are playing
football buzzing around
yeah i'm back being i'm back to myself
from the back normal
what's your role in this defense tell me
how you're you're
you're right in the middle of it all
devon what's going on
um basically what you just said i mean
i'm i'm right in the middle of it so
you can say i'm the i'm the hub of
communication i have to
communicate with uh 10 other guys about
you know
what we plan and what to expect and you
know we all got to be on the same page
so
you know that's a big part of my job
just making sure everybody's on the same
page and
you know we play a defense together so
you've got the helmet with the plays
coming in your head
yes sir you do and so you so walk me
through how you communicate
before snap what do you got for me devon
uh
so basically if it first starts you know
we we get a personnel meaning
uh we we depend uh depends on who's on
the field you know which players the
offense put on the field
uh we go from there then we go through
our play calling uh we pick a play
i echo the play from coming from the
sideline
uh other other ten echoes to play you
know if you have any checks anything we
we see or anything that we want to you
know get done you know uh
i'm i am one of the first people to uh
say that or make a check and i got other
guys you know helping me out with checks
and making sure we're all on the same
page
so in a way would it be appropriate to
say quarterback of the defense
would appropriate to say that yeah yeah
okay
if you want to well i mean no no i just
said that so i'm just trying to figure
it out because
it gets yeah yeah you get you can say
that yeah okay cause you mean you don't
just put that that that responsibility
on
uh on anyone's shoulders you you've
gotta you gotta put it in the helmet of
somebody who understands the defense
who's got a specific
set of skills not just talent but brains
uh
in other words a michigan man right
there
you know you know how that is i do know
how that is
you know what devin um my guy chris
brockman saw where i was going i told
him
until i grabbed that passage i heard i
heard the chuckle
you heard the chuckle you know there's a
lot of laughter involving our school
right now
i don't understand it it's the ones that
that um couldn't get in
that's what happened the ones that you
know couldn't go to michigan so i mean
i agree you got to feel for him a little
bit there's something i just gotta
chuckle with him there's a lot of
laughter devin you know on the show
before
mine uh dan patrick um legend in the
business a great friend of mine i would
call him great friend he
he actually was at my wedding um 17
years 17 years ago took over the bar
started handing people jagermeister
shots i mean that's how far back
i go with dan oh well actually go far
back to 1996.
he had urban meyer on his show um
yesterday and
he said how bad did you did you ever
feel bad running the score up on
michigan two guys from ohio
yucking it up just uh cause you're just
just having a good time huh
yeah over over a spotted tee huh yucking
it
up devin what are we gonna do about this
we gotta win rich that's what we got we
gotta win first we gotta win once
you can't lie i mean we we've been down
bad in these these couple years you
can't lie about that but i mean
you know we'll bounce back one one day
at a time one game at a time one year at
a time i guess
okay well before we get to your your
current state
uh of affairs with your with your team
devin bush here on the rich rising show
you played on the metlife turf in week
one that is uh front and center for
certainly the 49ers organization saying
that the turf
um needed to be inspected that there was
something wrong with the turf did you
sense
did you sense that night there was yeah
i i personally when i went out there i
mean it was
it was kind of it was kind of like how
can i explain this it was kind of like
soft under your feet but it was also
like kind of cushion
after the game i was um i was pretty
sore like in my my calves and my
like lower part of my feet and stuff so
i mean i feel exaggerated coming from on
that one
okay but could could that be chalked up
to
the fact that you hadn't played uh in a
game because there was nothing
that would also be a factor too okay so
but you
there was there was a conversation
though amongst your teammates that
something
was up with the turf or you just um no
just like a personal thing because i i
came in the next day you know to get
treatment and
you know my my shins was kind of
bothering me a little bit okay and uh
you know like you said it could have
been just the first game just
having all that adrenaline and just you
know moving at a fast pace but
you know i do that usually doesn't
happen to me when i when
you know i play you know my shins don't
usually hurt
okay so and maybe devin um you know this
is just
me just spitballing here is it is it
maybe that the
the 49ers thought maybe it was right
around the logo of the field
uh in the center that uh did you
did you did you do anything to the turf
not not this time not just time
[Laughter]
we're seeing video though it might be
this time
i promise you you don't know if it was
me
oh yeah i don't know you definitely know
how to leave your mark on the center of
a
center of the field we're seeing that
right now okay
fantastic all right so it feels like
your team
is set up what about what how do you
feel
how do your teammates feel about the
steelers going into this
week three uh we we feel really good um
you know we we kind of got a mentality
of you know we gonna take this one game
at a time and uh
you know we just gonna continue to get
better you know each and every week
um you know every week is not gonna be a
perfect week and uh every week's gonna
be a battle you know in
the nfl so i mean we we're willing to to
accept that and we'll
uh you know you go out there and play as
hard as you can you're gonna you know
you're gonna have some mess-ups gonna
see some new things and we just wanna
get better and better
you know and see where that leads us did
tomlin write that on a card for you
because
that sounded just like mike tomlin to me
devin yeah i kind of read it
off the car he left him in the room
right now i'm glad that maybe
i'm glad that tomlin printed it out so
you could you could read it honestly
that sounded
taped the quarterback
you know yeah sure well you're the
quarterback of the defense that sounded
like thomas how has tomlin affected you
seriously how has tomlin affected you
your play your
your everything i mean he fed me a lot
um he's one of those guys he's just one
of those really really really good
leaders you know you got a lot of
confidence in him
and uh he you know he's not the guy to
just walk around and talk all day and
and say oh i do this i do that do this
do this like he kind of leads by example
first and then he follows up with a lot
of words and actions so i mean
all you have is the most respect for him
and you know you want to play for a guy
like that
okay and have you guys uh in the locker
room discussed
brianna taylor at all in the last 24
hours in the
uh grand jury uh decision that came out
of kentucky has that conversation come
up yeah it's definitely
come up it hasn't been really like
extensive but
you know we uh we all got different
views on it and
of course you know it's unfortunate uh
what happened but
you know we we still fighting man and we
trying to just stay positive through all
this and and you know we still got a job
to do
about the same time you know it's
outside of these locker rooms outside of
this building you know we we are still
you know you know like we're we're
people you know we're people in this
world you know we still got to live and
we still got to carry out our date just
like any normal other person would and
you know but it's you know we're just
like i said it's just unfortunate but
we'll start to stay positive and you
know we'll we'll see
where we're in where we leave where we
end up devin bush here on the rich eisen
show couple minutes left with the
linebacker right in the middle of that
defense and then
my gosh the assignment of desean watson
coming up this week what is the
challenge
for you devon he's a really really
really good quarterback
um you know his play speeds for himself
uh you see the texans believe in him you
know they just you know up some and gave
him some more money
so he's there he's going to be there for
a while so i mean everything goes
through him
um he's going to be a challenge for us
just uh he's a he makes really good
throws you know he's very of course he's
good with his feet
he's one of those playmakers you know
you seen last year in the playoffs when
he you know got out of that sag and made
that throw and
you know winning the game so i mean he's
he's that type of player that's that's
going to put to put the game on his back
you know when it's time for it
and uh we got to shut him down all right
devin
i appreciate the time i know you got a
lot going on you got a
lot lots happening in this world good
luck i appreciate it
and let's let's keep let's stay in touch
let's connect
let's connect now that big ten is
actually gonna start playing it seems
like december
yeah i gotta you gotta invite me over
your house one day okay we gotta watch
the football or something
okay you got it devin all right lock it
in lock it up we'll do that soon you
keep uh you keep crushing it you keep
doing your thing yeah
you got it that's seven bush the
quarterback of the defense the
pittsburgh steelers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here